what's up guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm
Brianna white Brianna white and Ryan
writes are gonna be tight tonight in
your eyesight here we go let's light it
up the day with praise 1up box unboxing
video we today don't show me the
pictures of the pamphlet this month's
theme is legend let's rock and roll
we have to open the box to get out the
pamphlet to make sure we need the name
of it so box is a little [ __ ] up
because of Brianna that's why it looks
like this we don't know what it looks
like we know we just reach in there and
grabbed it the best way to learn people
best way to learn if you want to get sex
tips go watch the movie Magnolia Tom
Cruise is in it first line respect the
[ __ ] and tame the cut I'm quoting Tom
Cruise are you sure yes I'm serious look
up the scene you'll probably find it
alright let's start with the first item
first item Brianna first item that's a
pamphlet why would you give me the
pamphlet that shows you everything
that's on it goes over there
starting with the toy out maybe I don't
want some toys right everything I could
use yourself
oh sweet diggity that's freaky I got a
little Deadpool I got a live Deadpool I
got a little Deadpool he's lived and
cool
SuperMario dog tag that's pretty cool
okay first we got some cards we got some
cards here flying squirrel yellow toad
focus it's in focus
Bowser book and then and then we'll show
you the dog tag hey you guys go now who
was the real pimp around here it's too
small for me it's gonna choke me
I like me I choke though huh imagine
Veronica what if you just take off the
duck enough keep the dog down yeah show
green to keep it up like I'll show you
guys how I used it in one second I don't
know if it's I guess I can't do my thumb
oh yeah this isn't this is really cool
you see she could choke me she could
choke me and then she could flick my
chin
a sign of dominance like that huh watch
try do it try it choking choke me woman
Wow if this is 100 years ago I'd be
cheating on you if only it was 100 years
ago are you ready for the big night yeah
oh oh I bet you like that don't you
oh wow oh wow I know you really like
these guys to do look at that
they'll the link Winky pretty sure it's
a crossover patch farmer Patrick that
link is sitting on the Iron Throne of
Game of Thrones so it's an Legend of
Zelda Iron Throne Master Sword thrilled
listen I don't pay the girls to come on
the channel so here you go real that's
for you
that's for you I love it that's what you
get thank you a patch thank you
you get a patch nothing else ready damn
ray next item I'm ready for the next
item no it's new but he's laying in his
bed in his pokeball Oh - its Jesus
Christ no I think it's Thor oh the
hammer whoever holds this hammer if
they'd be worthy shall possess my love
happy Valentine's Day that's cute
that's really cute guys look at him he
looks just like Jesus the Lord and
Savior of our time mmm our time okay
he is omnipresent are you ready for the
next I think actually I like this might
be my favorite thing zero to hero coffee
it's a cookie what's a koozie a bottle
or a can it's your cookies oh cool but
it's got Hercules and Pegasus on it that
is really cute you know oh thank god
you're here but no that's my favorite
thing that's cool
I want one where do I get one you get
one here on the reel region right yeah
you're serious I'm dead serious
you're not gonna take it back are you
sure I can have this yeah you don't know
anybody else that would want this more I
can name three other people I like you a
little more than them you ready for the
grand finale I'm ready for the grand
finale
I'm already are you ready now I'm ready
now it's a gray shirt guys it's a plain
gray shirt that's a nice shade of gray
we're of course kidding you can catch us
at the flapper stand-up comedy show this
Saturday at 6 p.m. oh that's cute hugs
of legend huh so it looks like these are
League of Legends characters I don't
actually play that game so I don't know
but they're all puns
so it's pugs of legend and I kinda like
a pug yeah you sew it now it's a wet one
two one two three four five six pugs of
legend legendary that's pretty cute you
know who would appreciate this is Dan
Seibert oh my gosh I bet he would did
you see him rocking the shirt I feel
like you make anything into pugs and
it's 5,000 times cuter I think that's
the rule like the mathematical equation
for cuteness is make it pugs pug born if
you guys want to one-up box you can go
to the link in the description box go
through the referral link I don't make
money unless you go through the referral
link click that button all I care about
is just click the button I just kind of
like getting the boxes I mean it's free
toys its authority
ya know these are really cool toys and I
don't have to buy a Valentine's Day card
I mean you know I got I get a new shirt
every month and just to go to that
referral link you get gifts to give to
girls I mean that's what you guys want
right 1up box helps the world
i'm ryan right you can subscriber the
real rejects white has a gaming channel
sibling rivalry you can check out her
channel has to say it's worth it and I
wanted to say follow me on Instagram and
Vine because I'm using that a lot more
lately she has an Instagram as well and
a Twitter check it out so Instagram at
vine is my forte posting a lot more
vines they're pretty funny I'm trying to
promote me thank you thank you thank you
see that's what you call the skills of
communication you take time to you know
make your point but then you allow the
other person to speak that way they are
also included in the conversation they
feel like they are contributing
something even though they might not
really be they feel that way skills of a
true leader right right leadership 101
leader look out for my seminar people